I'm James Marshall I'm not in the math
of the song the toughest foot race in
the world
it's six marathons in five days of
process of lava desert I'm trained like
a crazy man which is really boring so
whilst my powers to come on a job to
keep me company
this is jogging with James Melissa
George darling you want lots of awards
you've been nominated for a Golden Globe
yes
you've worked with some pretty big
directors and you're not bad-looking and
how you not a complete monster [ __ ] oh
yeah with friends like you to keep me my
place
on hunter sand the character is a spy
did you learn you're like really cool
like spy stuff
so learn how to run guns like this it's
very difficult I learned to look over my
shoulder with my guns we had to make
sure when you look you don't shoot
yourself like this I learn a street
fighting technical KZ which they talk to
bond born and Batman this is the first
female we took this fight technique did
you ever think you know it's a channel
that anger did you think about past
boyfriends and think right I'm just
gonna get this out now yeah sure
husbands anybody do you have a muscle on
your foot no no we're out of Utah
actually
completely so was there ever a point
then where I mean to be a champion
roller skater yeah like what in the
world when I turned 14 I came second a
new Junior Worlds for artistic skating I
was training as a skater and then I got
this shown in Australia could homeboy
they left home at 16 and I moved to
Sydney and I became an actress and then
I just had this acting bug I had a lot
inside me that I wanted to get out and I
thought it was fascinating the fact that
you could get paid and cry and play
these parts and live this other world
and and to me that was like
rollerskating - I was always performing
playing a character on skates and then
acting was just a natural segue
have a game here which is I think
hopefully you'll appreciate it's not I'm
in trouble
the game is called shag marry push off a
cliff don't push the clip oh my good
so what I'm gonna son dirt and it's just
I'm an investor so I borrowed this game
we're different men and four women
okay so I want to understand do you
attract huge marry if you were single
and why Ryan Gosling George Clooney and
Channing Tatum
I would actually shag Ryan Gosling shag
and marry George Clooney so why would
you marry George Manning cuz it is
amazing week okay shag and push off the
truth Paddington once I've shagged
Channing Oh shall I how you like you
invent your own lesser why not is that's
great I would never push the papers or
if I did I could just live in Italy and
just not as a stay so we have Beyonce
who has just been voted by GQ as the
hottest woman at the 21st century Marla
Kunis and Kate Blanchette I would marry
Cate Blanchett I would shag Beyonce and
I would push me off a cliff very easy
decision
none of them are invited to the Italian
villa
none of them Melissa thank you so much
being I'm talking to James best time
you've been really wonderful
blowing into that's the show thanks for
watching and subscribe it to GQ
you can trend us by following hashtag GQ
job like us and comment below have a
great day
how's it hanging I've been put more
glide on Oh
without the collide I do get a chafing
don't you run like this so you you don't
get chasing
you